here is Aaron Rogers on what it was like
to be attacked for being a conspiracy
theorist who wouldn't get back science
that can't be questions isn't isn't
science anymore it's propaganda right
and that was my problem with the whole
thing is science is propagated by peer
review yes and you have an idea and then
giving it to your colleagues or a study
group or an institution and then having
them review it yes and figure out did
you make any sense initially you were
saying that masks don't work or saying
that the might won't stop transmission
or by saying that the virus came from a
lab all those things would get you
kicked off of social media initially
those have all been proven to be true
anyone that questioned the mandates if
you question anything related to
diversity equity and inclusion all of
these things they label you these things
the machine then puts out comedians late
night host out there to label everybody
all of these awful things and it just
Marches On